welcome back to 8701
in this second chapter we will discuss
symmetries
and the importance of symmetries in
physics in general
but also especially in particle physics
and nuclear physics
so we start with a short introductory
video
and then we move on into more details as
we go along
the importance of symmetries cannot be
under stated in physics
and there's two aspects which are
important the first one is
that symmetries and conservation laws go
hand in hand
as discussed by mercer theorem
to to express the theorem in an informal
way you can say that
if a system has a continuous symmetry
property then there are corresponding
properties whose values do not change
with time
meaning that they are conserved you can
express this more sophisticated
and say to every differentiable symmetry
generated by local action there's
correspondence
there's a correspondent conserved
current and we're going to look at those
actions and currents as we go along
the second aspect beyond the fact that
there's conservation laws
is that you can understand um physics
experiments and nature
if you know that the physics have an
underlying
symmetry without fully understanding the
physics or the mathematical backgrounds
in order to do calculation
in detail so knowing that the underlying
symmetry can help
really expressing or understanding the
physics behavior of
experiments a few historic remarks on
emmy nurture eminota was born in germany
in
the 1880s in
erlangen on where she grew up and also
studied mathematics mathematics at the
university of alan
after getting her degree she worked for
a full seven years at the university
in the mass department and received zero
dollars
and not just because it wasn't the
currency being used there
but at that time a woman didn't really
have a prominent role in academia and so
there was no
job for her to take um but her
talents and her qualification was seen
in the mathematical worlds at the time
uh specifically in the center of the
mathematical world which wasn't cutting
um so hilbert basically discovered her
and asked her to come to gottingen
um in order to do habilitation she had
did
get an habilitation and getting in 1919
and then stayed in gottingen till the
situation in europe degraded
in the 1930s and then she was born
um jewish and
couldn't stay in gerting and beyonce
1933 and then had to immigrate
into the united states where she
worked at brian moyer
college and also with princeton
her work i mean you see here her
habilitation which is in german
invariant variations problem in
in variant variational problems um
was highly regarded and you had a lot of
influence and impact
on various strands in mathematics and
physics
unfortunately she passed away already
when she was about
50 years old she you know was diagnosed
with some sort of
cancer and passed away really really
quickly after this
after some surgery um her temperature
rise and a few days later
she was she passed away
um to come back to symmetries and
conservation laws
um so every symmetry of nature yields a
conservation law
that is what inertia theorem tells you
and you can revert this to saying that
every conservation law in physics
reflects an underlying symmetry and
examples for this are the fact that
you know the the properties the laws of
physics are invariant under
time translation meaning that physics is
the same yesterday
the same tomorrow and it's going to be
the same next week and out of this we
can reduce
energy conservation similarly
translation in space results in
momentum conservation angular rotations
or rotations without an angular momentum
and then a little bit harder to grasp
but we will see this in more detail
internal symmetries can also lead to
conservation loss
and gauge transformation to the
conservation of charge
so there's internal symmetries as well
um before we dive into more detail a few
things you know those
those in many cases um
symmetry symmetry operations can be
expressed via mattresses
um or groups and uh there's a few
um uh
rules or you know operations which are
rather important and
define define symmetry the first one is
that
you know any any symmetry operation has
to have identity
meaning there has to be an operation
which doesn't do anything
with an element of this group there has
to be closure
meaning that if you apply a first
transformation and then a second
the resulting transformation is again
as part of the set of transformations
now there's an inverse meaning that you
know if you rotate in one direction you
can rotate back
um and there's an associativity
meaning that you know if you have a
rotation
acting on two other rotations you can
regroup
and and follow what's shown in this
equation here
it's not clear that you can revert the
order of a certain
elements of your of your group or your
symmetry operation
um you can classify them however those
where you can commute
are those called billion groups and
those where you cannot
those are non-orbiting um
all right so with this um
we have introduced with the first
video symmetries and now we just dive
into more detail and understanding
continuous imageries and also discrete
symmetries
and what we can learn from them